foreign
for six years to a flooded leather bag
and a boat cover left outside to face
the elements these forgotten items
became breeding grounds for mold we
spoke with experts to find out how they
cleaned and sanitized them
[Music]
our first expert is Brent decheza from
WD detailing he shows us how he and his
team clean a car filled with rain water
and mold they start by pumping oxygen
into the car using an ozone machine
the oxygen suffocates and kills bacteria
they remove the seats and vacuum out all
of the water that is pulled on the floor
because the sunroof of the car won't
close rain water has dripped inside and
collected for six years
[Music]
Brent uses an air compressor with a
tornado or attachment to blastly carpet
fibers with an all-purpose cleaner mixed
with water then he sprays extractor soap
on the carpet before using an extractor
to shoot it with hot water the extra
moisture will help to reduce friction as
he uses a drill brush to agitate the
soap too much friction could further
damage the carpet
after agitating he uses the extract to
suck the soap and water out of the
carpet
the team sprays the doors with a
bacteria killing solution called
triclean before scrubbing them down with
the tornado door attachment
to dry the doors they use a microfiber
cloth and another tornado door
attachment that blows out air
they vacuum the seats to collect any
surface debris and then spray them with
a leather cleaner
then they use a color lock brush to
scrub deep into the pores of the seeds
making sure they don't use too much
pressure
sprays the seats again and uses a
steamer to kill any lingual bacteria
to clean the wheels they start by
pressure washing them to remove initial
dirt and grime then they spray them with
heavy acid agitate them and wash away
the solution
mold is even accumulated on the exterior
of the car so they pressure wash it
twice applying paint safe Degreaser
between sessions finally they spray soap
onto the car using a foam Cannon wipe it
down with microfiber mitts and rinse it
with water to prevent a car stored
outside from becoming moldy it's best to
store it under a car cover or top
[Music]
foreign
is Charlotte sturg from the handbag
Clinic she demonstrates how her team
restores a leather handbag that looks
unsalvageable due to mold growth this
handbag was sitting in the back of its
owner's Wardrobe when a pipe burst
leaving the perfect environment for mold
to spread
after assessing the handbag an artisan
from Charlotte's team begins scraping
the mold away using a variety of hand
tools metal tools can be used in areas
where the leather is harder wearing or
the mold is not sticking to the bag
otherwise a wooden tool is used to avoid
scratching the leather
next they use a brush to remove any dry
mold left over after scraping
The Artisan sprays a mold removal
solution onto the bag to ensure the mold
is killed so it won't grow back
finally they apply an in-house cleaner
to the bag to remove any harsh chemicals
or remaining dirt and then it's ready to
be returned to its owner
foreign
[Music]
this cover certainly did its job
protecting a boat from the elements but
now it needs a good cleaning Mike
Sadowski from Chet's cleaning gets it
looking as good as new Mike spray is The
Moldy boat cover with a chemical
solution called Dot and then allows it
to dwell for at least 30 minutes then he
uses a machine called a cymax to agitate
the cymax gently pulls apart the fibers
of the boat cover so that dirt mold and
grime can be released
power washes with soap and water to
further break up the dirt and then he
uses a broom to push the pulled water
off of the boat cover this helps him see
whether he's missed any spots
Mike puts the belt cover into a bath to
rinse off the chemicals and then runs it
through a rinse finger to squeeze out
the water and power wash it one more
time before hanging it to dry
[Music]
Mike recommends getting boat covers
cleaned when they start to look dirty
applying water repellent can also
prolong the life of a boat cover
[Music]
foreign